hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
in saint augustine's confessions book
five doesn't begin as such but it's very
early on in book five that we find
augustine bringing into question his
semi-commitment to manichaeism
and this happens because of his
encounter with somebody who's supposed
to explain it all who is not able to
explain it all not able to provide the
intelligibility the answers that
augustine
is looking for and manichaeism is is
something that he is attracted to
on
you know much to the chagrin of his
orthodox catholic mother monica who
would prefer of course that he's within
the
christian church manichaeism is kind of
a blend of several different
religions
brought together by mani that's why it's
called manichaeism which became
effectively a world religion and a rival
both to christianity and to other
religions within the roman empire one
thing you can say about it is that it is
a gnostic take so it's one of the
varieties of gnosticism there are many
different varieties very often at odds
with each other
and you know what does this mean there's
a doctrine that the human beings are
essentially
sparks of the divine caught up in matter
maybe not all human beings are like that
some are just you know meat mechanisms
and there's ways to get ourselves out of
that to ascend beyond the world which
was created by a
bad deity that thinks that it's really
the you know the top deity but we want
to get out of that and so there are
aesthetic practices there's all sorts of
teachings by manny himself who views
himself as being sort of the culmination
of a religious path that is being taught
by other people prior to
manny coming for instance jesus christ
they say that the christians have
effectively judaized
the the christian revelation and
scriptures it also traces back to
siddhartha gautam of the buddha and to
zoroaster but manny is actually doing
his own writings and you know brings
about this community that augustine is
engaged with and he's finding that he's
got a lot of
doubts by this time
augustine has been you know off and on
reading christian scriptures not finding
a lot helpful in those at that point in
the work for him they haven't been
opened up adequately he's also studied
quite a few of the philosophers and you
know probably more than are mentioned in
here you know we we know that he for
example has read cicero's hortensius and
that's got him going into it we know
that he's read the academic skeptics we
know that he's going to be he's either
read or is going to be reading the
plaintiffs he's you know read epicureans
he would have encountered this in his
profession of teaching rhetoric in part
because it wasn't as if there was a hard
and fast dividing line here's where
philosophy is here's where rhetoric is i
mean aristotle himself wrote a book on
rhetoric right that was used as one of
the handbooks and so augustine has had a
chance to you know see what philosophers
have to say
and he tells us that when i compared the
doctrines of the philosophers with the
long fables of the manikins i found much
more probable the words of the
philosophers
who were quote able to know so much as
to make a judgment of the world although
it's lord they did not find and then he
says you know the philosophers
they're able to make sense out of the
natural world
they're not quite ascending from it up
to god so there's um you know a
significant issue there but he says by
their own minds and that ingenuity with
which you endowed them they investigated
these matters what matters the stars and
the sands the constellations the courses
of the planets many years in advance
they foretold eclipses of the great
luminaries the sun and the moon telling
on what day at what hour and what extent
they would be and their calculations did
not
fail them and so this is you know this
is good this is a knowledge this is
something kind of cool
and now what import does this have
augustine goes on to say you know they
um
they didn't know you god right they
suffer an eclipse of of your light but
they certainly seem to know a hell of a
lot more than these mannequins
do right
um and and so you know they're they're
missing something but they're also
providing you know some understanding of
like he says
solstices equinoxes eclipses of the
greater lights and who doesn't actually
explain this adequately
manny so
mandy has all sorts of other things when
augustine is saying about fables he
means a kind of mythology right a mythol
agnostic mythology
and manny writes about natural phenomena
at points but unfortunately gets them
wrong
so he says
who was it that requested someone called
manny to write about these things apart
from knowledge in these matters true
piety can yet be learned you know of
this manny could be ignorant even though
he knew the other matters perfectly but
in truth
he did not know these subjects yet
brazenly presumed to teach them he
plainly could not attain to knowledge of
piety so he's missing two things
knowledge of god
knowledge of the natural
world and so you know when you compare
him to the other natural philosophers
that are out there
manny looks kind of silly and he looks
kind of foolish and
you know
this is not augustine saying i'm
throwing this out all together but it
certainly calls things into question
there's a very interesting digression
that i don't want to pass over in these
chapters
about the relationship between religion
and natural philosophy one that i think
is relevant
for people even in our time so augustine
says
when i hear this or that brother
christian who's ignorant of these
subjects and thinks one thing in place
of another
i can regard such a man with patience as
he gives his opinion i cannot see how it
will harm him if he's perhaps an
ignorant with regard to the position or
condition of some corporeal creature
like the heavenly bodies
so long
as
he he does believe things uh
unworthy of you lord creator of all
things however it is very harmful to him
if he thinks that this belongs to the
very essence of religious teaching and
obstinately presumes to assert what he
is ignorant of such weakness in the
cradle days of a man's faith is put up
with by charity
until this person grows up
but as to that one who dared to become
the teacher you know he goes on with
that um
what is he actually saying there you
know when it comes to natural phenomena
if christians get those wrong you know
if they think uh that you know
reign is is god you know shedding tears
over the unhappiness of mankind or
something like that who cares
that's just somebody being ignorant
you know unless they're actually drawing
conclusions about what god is which
could be the case right does god get sad
or about how we ought to behave faith
and morals we could say
it doesn't matter
and we hear we can think about something
you know when the galileo incident which
is much more complex than the thumbnail
sketches that people provide occurred
galileo was actually like trying to
engineer a crisis of his own in the the
church at least the members of the
church there
involved with him were also being kind
of jerks and digging in there were many
people increa in christendom who are
like
this is not a real thing
you're
you know whether the earth rotates
around the sun or the planets or you
know whether things fall at certain uh
speeds in relation to each other pick
whatever experiment you want from
physical science
it doesn't really impinge
on what we should be focusing on right
it's not going to kill anybody to have
mistaken ideas about this when it comes
to you know merely physical matters
you know so long as they've got their
other as we say their other ducks in a
row and so augustine is saying something
that's kind of
important here to keep in mind
now coming back to the the faustus thing
so why is augustine so
interested in faustus
he tells us this is in chapter six
for almost nine years during which my
errant mind had hearken to these men the
manikins i awaited with intense longing
the coming of
this faustus right and he says that you
know
because faustus is going to be here i
can actually ask the questions and get
real answers
others among them who had chance to meet
failed to answer my questions and
objections but they promised me
that when he came and took part in these
discussions these problems even harder
ones i might present would be easily and
clearly settled so
raising the
expectations pretty high right but
reasonably so if a religion is going to
be
worth anything or you could say a
philosophy or a political doctrine there
ought to be somebody
who can make sense of it and address
objections right we can say this with
like stoicism for example if you read
you know some stoic literature and
you're like
this doesn't make sense to me i've got
all sorts of objections
hopefully there's somebody who's
actually
thought those things through and can can
explain it adequately well it's the same
thing with manichaeism what does
augustine find so he finds that in
public
in the crowd this faustus guy seems like
he's on top of everything
when he came i found he was gracious and
pleasant
in his conversation on the topics on
which they usually speak he could talk
along much more agreeably
but
could he actually address things
in reality and he says you know
this wasn't the case
and i found this out by hanging out with
faustus personally he says um here we go
i was delighted with him together with
many others indeed more so than many of
them i praised and excluded but i took
it a miss
that in the midst of a crowd of
listeners i could not bring forward and
share with him my own worrisome
questions in personal conferences and by
offering and receiving arguments when i
was able to do this what happens
i began with some friends to lay siege
to his ears right i set forth certain
things that were disturbing me and i saw
at once
the man was unskilled in the liberal
arts with the exception of grammar and
with that only in an elementary way he'd
read some of cicero's orations a few
books of seneca certain things of the
poets and whatever volumes of his sect
were written in
latin and he had an easy eloquence
but he couldn't
satisfactorily answer the questions on
the basis of knowledge or even on the
basis of what other people are saying
because he doesn't have a strong solid
basis in the liberal arts augustine is
finding out that actually maybe
this guy is a teacher augustine can't
learn much from him because
augustine already knows more
and you know what is what is uh faustus
doing
he augustine says the manikins books are
filled with long spun out tales of the
heavens the stars the sun and the moon
having compared their accounts with the
mathematical solutions i read elsewhere
i didn't think that faustus was able to
explain these matters with exactness
or
to show that that they are such as is
found in manic manny's books or that an
equally good solution could be drawn
from these
and now faustus
to his credit
is rather modest he's actually honest
he's like uh you know i don't actually
know this stuff
i can't explain this and he says he knew
that he did not know these subjects he
was not ashamed to admit it right
but he says he was not completely
ignorant of his own ignorance he didn't
want to engage rashly in a discussion
from which he had no way out or no easy
way of retreat he appealed to me the
more for this this is something that
augustine says this is a good trait of
faustus
the more beautiful than all those things
i desire to know is the modest mind that
admits its own limitations but
these are still limitations and so
augustine is not getting what he's
looking for from faustus
there's a very interesting
metaphor that we're seeing at the end of
chapter seven
he tells us that faustus himself was a
snare
or a noose something that you would be
you would be hung by something you would
be captured by a locais in latin faustus
was a snare of death to many how was he
a snare of death to many by giving them
the impression that they actually knew
things about god
about how they ought to live by teaching
a false doctrine and doing so in such a
way that was convincing to other people
but augustine says something really
interesting here
uh so that was to other people and he
says he now began faustus began neither
knowing
nor willing it to loosen the snare in
which i was caught what is the snare
in which augustine is caught
you know a commitment to manichaeism and
a sort of counter commitment to thinking
that the christian scriptures don't
really
make sense so it's
you know a
turning point for augustine to actually
meet this guy
and to realize that he's not going to
get from faustus
what it is that he was hoping for either
from faustus or from manichaeism and
this allows him to be able to move on
with his quest
that runs throughout the
entirety of the bio autobiographical
portions
of his confessions
you